Hello world, it's Saroj. And can a
computer make better usic than you?
Maybe it's close to doing.
So in this video,
we're going to talk about AI to generate
music and I've got a great demo for you.
It's using deep learning
to generate music.
And what we can do is we can change the
genre of music by tuning these sliders.
Let's,
let's take a little demo sample.
All right.
Anyway. Okay. There we go. So that's the,
that's the demo for this video.
It's a simple web app.
It's using a deep learning
model in the backend at to,
to generate these sounds
that was pretrained on a
Dataset of monophonic piano
notes. And we'll talk about
all of that, right? So we,
we have to get to where we need to be.
That means we have to start off with, um,
hidden Markov models,
then moved to recurrent networks and
finally get to a generative adversarial
networks,
which is the demo that I'm going to
talk about at the end of this video code
included, of course, because we love
code. If you don't code, you should code.
All right? So anyway, so let's start
with the history. Just one little,
one little snippet of
pre, uh, pre software.
So before there was any
software, uh, we were,
music is older than language and
before there was any software,
the first automatic music
came from nature. So when
chimes, for example, or the,
or an ancient Greek wind powered Ionian,
harp sores, Japanese water instruments,
et Cetera, et Cetera, et
cetera. But in the 17 hundreds,
the first automatic
music became algorithmic.
So there was a German game that
generated short piano compositions from
fragments, which choices made by dice.
Just want to give you a little fun little,
you know, pre software before we get into
the good stuff, just so you know that.
Okay, so that was then, now we're getting
into the 19 hundreds and then onto,
onto now the Markov chain.
Very, very cool model.
It's used in weather prediction.
It's used and it's been
used in speech recognition.
It's been used in a lot of fields.
It's be,
it's been using all of the sciences
for sure. Biology, physics,
Markov chains have been used
extensively. But anyway, um, it's,
it's a very simple, basic idea. And I
have this little slide right here to,
to show, uh, a little bit about Markov
chains that I'm taking from Clemson.
But basically the
motivation is in this case,
it's always about predicting
the next data in a sequence.
That data could be a word, it could be
a musical note, it could be some speech,
but it's all about predicting the next
data in a sequence. And what it is,
is it's a,
it's,
it's a basically a graph that shows
probabilities of going from one point to
another and by points,
those points could be data points,
like strings for example, right? So if
you have the word, what if I say the word,
what?
There's a certain that the next word will
be is there's a certain probability to,
the next word will be the, and
based on those probabilities, this,
the computer can traverse that graph to
maximize for the probabilities so that
the most likely word is said or generated.
And that's the same thing goes for music.
And these had been used, like I said,
and whether, for example, right,
so if we have three states,
sunny, rainy, and cloudy,
and depending on the inputs,
it could be any of those things.
What a hidden Markov model does is it
models all of those state transition
probabilities from sunny to, to rainy
to whatever it is, right? So let's say,
you know, if it's rainy, then there's
a 60% chance it's going to be,
it's going to be cloudy,
right?
And it's going to be 60% less than it's
going to be sunny, right? So there is,
there was some relationship between all
of these states that can be modeled as
probability values. And that's
what, that's what it's for, right?
And so what it comes down to is
just basic multiplication, right?
Because when a hidden Markov model does,
is it doesn't just,
it doesn't generate completely novel data.
It generates data that is a subsection
of the existing data, right?
So the best way to explain what I mean
by that is for us to look at a bit of a
bit of code, right? So let's look at
some code. For this hidden Markov Model.
It's right here.
This 25 lines snippet of Python
code is a hidden Markov model.
Okay? So in this case, we have two
words. Okay. These are strings. Um,
what we were going to do is we're going
to create a table out of all of these
words are, and then what we're
gonna do is we're going to say,
let's generate some
output by learning those,
those probability values
between those words.
So it's a learning that the likelihood
that one word will come after another,
and it's basically just picking
a random word from the next word.
And we can print that out, right? So this
is a very, very simple model and it's,
it's, it's just basic multiplication
is what it boils down to.
Multiplication from some
existing set of data. Um,
and then learning the
probabilities of these words.
Just one by one by one, right?
So,
um,
one example of an artist
that used a Markov chain to
generate music was in 1958.
His name was Ian is Xenakis and use it
in his 1958 composition and a logic which
we can listen to. Thanks to the
power of the Internet, right?
Yeah. So that sounds terrible. But anyway,
uh, that was what he did. So that's,
that's what it was. It was, it was, it
was modeling the probabilities of a,
of a note occurring after a certain
sequence of notes. That's what it did.
And so that basic idea of modeling the
probability of a note occurring next is
kind of like the constant of
using AI to generate music, right?
Because when we have some piece of
music, it's a sequence of notes, right?
All music is sequential and there was
some likelihood that a certain note to
will come next after a certain set
of notes have already occurred.
And we can model that with
a hidden Markov model.
But I hidden Markov model can only produce
sub sequences that also exist in the
original data.
But what if we want to extrapolate beyond
those exact sub sequences and create
really novel, um, data that's generated.
And that's where recurrent networks come
into play. Recurrent neural networks.
In 1989 the first attempt to generate
music with the recurrent net was limited
by their short term coherence.
So someone tried to
uh, generate music, uh,
in his style,
a Bach using recurrent
networks in 1989 and uh,
it was limited because it can
only grasp short term sequences,
right? So if if Bach hat of
a huge piece with, you know,
four different sections,
it would stop, it would,
it would forget about the beginning part
in the beginning was very soft and the
second part was very strong and the
third part was like mellow and right.
What a recurrent network does normally
without any kind of variation to it is it
will.
So normally a neural network will learn
the hidden state based on every new data
point that it's fed. Right? Every new data
point. That's it. And it's learning, it's,
it's, it's like, think of it
like clay, it's like molding,
it's internal representation to become
robust against all variations of that
input data,
whether it's images of stop signs,
whether it's a musical notes, it's
learning some abstraction of all of that.
So then using that obstruction,
we can generate new notes.
But what we're current networks
will do is in every time step,
it's not just learning
based on the new data point,
it's learning based on the
previously learned abstraction.
So at every time step
that obstruction is fed,
not just a new data point but
an older version of itself.
So there is a recurrence there.
And what this does is it lets it
lets it lets us learn from sequences.
The problem is that a recurrent network
can't learn longterm sequences because
of what's called the
vanishing gradient problem.
I'm not going to talk about
the vanishing gradient,
but just search vanishing
gradient Saroj on, on Youtube.
But basically we want to wait to trap
that memory that's being back propagated
across time to get a little technical.
And the solution to that was, you know,
the yard, the solution was to use what's
called a long short term memory network,
an LSTM network. And let's listen to
a bit of this. A recurrent network.
Okay.
Yeah. So that was better that we have
to admit that was better than before.
Not necessarily Hans Zimmer
status, but it was better. Um, so,
so Doug [inaudible] was
one of the first in 2002.
Now we're like 16 years ago,
so we're getting closer to switch from
using a standard recurrent network to
what's called a long short term memory
network and this improve the architecture.
It improved what the,
what the model could generate.
Now Doug works in for the
Magenta team at Google brain.
Magento has been developing a code for
generating music using machine learning
and they are really on the
bleeding edge of this stuff.
Magenta has made so many cool
different little products that we can,
we can view in the, in the
browser. But the thing is,
even though we're current networks
have been around for awhile,
it wasn't very much common knowledge
until Andre carpathy posted the
unreasonable effectiveness
of recurrent networks in May,
2015 which was more than a decade later,
which is incredible if you think about it,
the power of good documentation can
move the masses to try some code.
What Andrea used his recurring network
on was generating Shakespearian text so
it would train on Shakespeare text and
then it would be able to generate text.
In this style of what it had
just trained on Shakespeare.
Uh,
so what I have here is a very
simple LSTM network. Okay.
So for just for us to get an idea
of what it looks like, right.
So
we are defining our nonlinearities,
which are our activation functions,
which makes sure our network can learn
both non linear and linear functions.
We then define a training datasets. We
have our hyper parameters listed up here.
We initialize the weights of our three
layer neural network and then inside of
our training loop we
start training this thing.
We performed the simple addition problem.
We then update the
deltas to show that hey,
there's a certain change in the weight
values and now that we've co computed a
certain change in the
weight values we can,
we can update those weights by performing
an optimization technique called back
propagation,
also known as gradient descent.
See my video backpropagation
in five minutes.
What I need is basically just like a
tree to just connect all of my videos
across the cause. All of these topics.
By the way, if you don't understand,
just search to Raj and then
the name of that topic.
And I promise you I have a video on that.
So,
okay.
And
we're updating those weights were making
sure that the gradient is not vanishing,
that it's trapped properly inside of each
of those synapses and it's being back
propagated properly as well. Um, but yeah,
so moving forward, so September, 2016,
two years ago now, we're
getting really, really close,
deep mind published their seminal paper
on what's what they called wavenet. Okay.
So wave net was,
uh,
an an architecture that generated
state of the art human sounding speech.
Okay. So no model up to that point had
made speech that sounded so human like,
and people who were very surprised
because no one had done that.
And here's the real key to it.
Here's the real kicker to all of this.
Wave Net was not a recurrent network.
It was a convolutional network. What?
Right.
So convolutional networks are used for
learning from images and we're current
networks are used for,
for learning from sequences.
But what deepmind did is they use a
convolutional network to learn to process
images by treating time
like a spatial dimension,
which is very interesting stuff.
Anyway,
wave net was was it required massive
amounts of Gpu like seriously and then
later on someone made a fast version of
Wavenet, which you can find on get hub,
just search fast wave net.
But then fast forward a year later,
Magenta built on top of
wavenet to create end synth,
which we can try from the browser.
It's basically a sound maker that lets
us try out different instruments and
combined them together and make all new,
all new sounds out of it.
So up to this point, there
are some, there are some,
there are certain important questions
in this space that we have to answer
rights. How do we decide on a
proper representation of music?
What music data should we use?
Whose music counts box or an Edm artist?
You know,
do we want to learn from the entire
documented history of music with the big
goal of producing something
similar or something novel?
Or should we try to construct
entire compositions or,
or to improvise with us?
Do we want this to replace us?
Do we want it to augment
us? Right. That's, that's a
major question for us to ask.
Well,
when it comes to startups in this space,
and this is a part of the
AI for business series,
this is why I'm teaching
you this stuff because we,
there's definitely a space
to create businesses that,
that help artists improved their sounds
using AI to help consumers be able to
become artists in a way
that they couldn't before.
By giving them the tools to make
orchestral sounds, for example, that were,
that would require a hundred human
people and you know, in the past,
and you could just do it with a web app.
Now juke deck is one example of a
startup that lets anybody create music.
You could select the mood style temple
in length and it uses AI to do this in
the background. And there's a, there's
a subscription model you can pay.
You can get your first five songs a month
free and then you pay seven USD attrac
for 150 bucks. Creators can even buy
the exclusive copyright for those songs.
And these are songs that
are generated by AI,
which means their bottom line is zero,
which means that they
are making some money.
This is a great business model
genius. And, and there's, there's a,
there's huge room in this space for more
of that. Eva is another example, right?
So what they do is they
do music composition.
It was founded last year in London and
it's taught to compose classical music,
which they already have clients, film,
film directors, advertising agencies,
game studios.
Ampere is another example.
I talked about this with Taryn southern
and uh, you know, a couple months now ago.
Uh, but that's what she used.
That was a tool that she used to,
to help generate music.
There was started by,
it needs to be a film composer who
wanted to make music that was more of a
collaboration between humans and machines.
It does basically the same thing.
IBM's Watson. So this is not a
startup. This is a big company,
but even there are going into this
space and they're using their cognitive
technology. By the way, Ibm guys,
let's stop using the word cognitive.
Let's start using the word, you know,
deep learning or AI or machine learning.
There's nothing cognitive about what
you're doing. Anyway. Don't hate me.
Ibm. I still love you. Okay, so
you know. Anyway, just let's stop.
Let's stop trying to make it seem like,
you know,
the human brain is like inside of some
server. That's not where we are right now.
Anyway, where were we? So architecture.
Okay, so that's the history.
Up until now,
a couple of years ago,
Ian Goodfellow released a paper called
generative adversarial networks that
allows for novel way to generate data.
And I think that, and this is now,
now we're going into, now we're going from
objective to subjective, right? So I'm,
I'm telling you my opinion now.
My opinion is that the way forward is to
use a generative adversarial network to
generate sounds that would give us
better results than a recurrent network,
an LSTM network, a hidden Markov
model, a convolutional neural networks.
Even better than wavenet because gans
are truly a new technology that they have
not properly been harnessed.
And video harness them pretty well for
this paper on generating faces like in
real time was very cool. But again,
these are notoriously hard to train.
There's a lot that can be improved
of the space is moving so fast. Um,
and what I have here, by the
way, is this good humbling,
you should definitely check it out.
It's called music generation
with deep learning, huge,
huge collection of
resources for you to use.
If you want to learn more about this
space, papers from all across the board,
from all sorts of countries,
blog posts, code, uh,
conferences and workshops related to
music generation with AI applications that
you can play with in the browser. Super
useful stuff. Definitely check it out,
but I want to talk about it again right
now. Okay. So again, has two parts.
It's got a generator and it's got
a discriminator. And both of these,
most of these are neural networks.
Okay? So one's job is to generate data.
The other job is to look at
what the generator generated
and discriminate it and
say this is real or this is fake. It's
binary, zero or one. That's what it does.
And so with the power and ease of care
os we can create a generator in one line.
That's right. One Line of code.
We could create a neural network,
define oldest perimeters and call it a
generator. Okay. So that's our generator.
What it will do. So in this example, it's
generating an image in the style of it,
this handwritten digits.
But we can generate music sounds right.
So what the generator will do is
it will take in that input image.
Okay.
It will learn some latent representation.
That's a collection of numbers
and this in this image,
you can see that and then it will,
it will vary it a little bit.
So it generates something entirely new.
And this is a series of operations, right?
And this, and it's going to
start off totally random, right?
Like how would it know how to vary this
input data? It doesn't know. It's dumb.
It's just like, oh, let me just multiply
by X. And then the vibe, okay, the,
the real learning comes from this.
When it generates that new sample,
the discriminator, we'll say that's real
or it's fake. At first, the discriminator,
we'll be able to tell
immediately that this is real.
And this is fake because the discriminator
has been trained on the training data
as well. So they will know, oh,
that's not a real sequence
of notes that's fake.
That because I know that that sequence
of notes is a part of the training data.
Okay.
So talking about music,
when that discriminator makes that
a classification and says it's fake,
then the generator will need to update
itself. So using backpropagation,
so both networks are back propagated
so that the optimization technique will
slowly shift those wait values. And so
the operations will slowly shift as well.
So the next time that some data
is going through the generator,
it's going to be more likely to generate
something that is harder to discern
whether it's real or fake. And so the
whole point of this process, I'm not like,
I'm not like,
I'm like not even reading the notes
because I know gans so well now,
but the whole point of this process
is so the generator becomes so good at
generating something that
the discriminator cannot
tell if it's real or if it's
fake. And you can think of it
as like a cat and mouse game.
You can think of it as like
a police and a counterfeiter.
Eventually the counterfeiter gets so
good that the police cannot tell if the
money is real or fake,
and that's what we're trying to do.
The point of generative adversarial
network is not the discriminator.
The point is the generator.
That's what we want.
When the whole thing is trained and
to end, we remove the discriminator.
We take that generator and we just
start generating. In our case,
it would be pieces of
music and musical notes.
Once we have those pieces of music,
that is our song that we can then play.
Now it's easier to generate music
that is monophonic. Right? So the,
these are a single notes,
piano notes.
We get whatever Harb notes, but most
music comes in the form of chords, right?
Collections of notes, polyphonic and
that's a little bit harder to train,
but I think again, these are the way
forward to to, to make that happen. Okay,
so that's how that goes.
I had this sample here called Gan music
and basically if you want an idea of
what it looks like programmatically,
here's what it is, right?
So these are our parameters for both D,
which is the discriminator and g,
which is the generator. And these are
just wait values and bias, values,
input times weight, add a bias activate.
That's how every neural network works.
Just remember that. So now we have
our generator and our discriminate.
We define them right here. Here's our
generator, here's a discriminator.
We were using tensor flow to create
both of them. We can plot them,
see the difference. We can
create a sample and say, okay,
here's the real and here's the fake.
We have two loss functions,
one for the real, one,
one with for the fake,
and then we solved them
both using gradient descent.
This is our optimization strategy.
And at the end we can print it out
and we can plot is very simple.
This was like hundred 36 lines of code
with tensorflow to create again and you
just drag and drop your music
dataset and boom, you're good. Um,
so yeah, this, um, this
demo, it's on get hub,
check it out as well.
Check out my links.
I have some great links for
you in the video description.
There's a lot of
potential to use AI to uh,
create services for both artists
and consumers regarding music.
And really if you want to extrapolate
to all sorts of entertainment,
everything I've talked about, your
can be applied to text to, you know,
essays to songs, to poetry, to
images, to video even, right?
All of this,
all of this is sequential data and
because all of this is sequential data,
we can, we can, we can generate
it, we can learn from it.
Then we can generate new sequences
and this can help all sorts of people.
There's a huge business use case for this
and now is the time because all these
tools are just now starting
to be democratized.
We now have access to a
GPU is via cloud providers.
We now have access to algorithms.
We now have access to data sets.
We now have access to education, right?
So all this is being democratized.
It's your responsibility to do something
about it. Um, that Santa my Spiel,
and I hope you found this video useful.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got to listen to some music,
AI music. So thanks for watching.